[Música]
bueno continuamos en este cubrimiento
especial de france 24 de la novena
cumbre de las américas y me hace un
espacio en su agenda el canciller de
argentina santiago cafiero muchas
gracias por acompañarnos en france 24
equipos bien bueno primero que todo
quiero preguntarle hubo mucha
información sobre primero si venía usted
como representante de argentina o si iba
a venir el presidente alberto fernández
en persona que motivó a que el
presidente viniera en persona en primer
lugar
terminar de conversar con los líderes de
la región con muchos de ellos por lo
menos
y dejar bien claro cuál era el mensaje
que en su carácter también de presidente
de la celac de la comunidad de estados
latinoamericanos y caribeños se quería
presentar aquí en la cumbre
ese fue el tiempo un tiempo de consulta
de ponerse de acuerdo
con algunos de los líderes de la región
y efectivamente creo que lo principal es
que el presidente fernández hizo
un gran discurso tuvo una presentación
destacada porque planteó los nuevos
desafíos de la integración
en nuestro continente
y son desafíos que lo que se busca es
construir nuevas nuevas una nueva
arquitectura
en cuanto a la integración regional y
para construir esa arquitectura bueno
ahí hay muchas de las críticas que hay
que lograr hacerla así que tenemos que
ser honestos entre nosotros y poder
decir qué es lo que no está funcionando
bien y qué es lo que tiene que cambiar
si no somos capaces de decir eso con
franqueza entonces nunca vamos a
construir algo distinto
el presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro dijo específicamente que el
mensaje era del mensaje del presidente
fernández iba a ser su mensaje esto fue
así
no no sé qué dijo el presidente maduro
pero no el mensaje del de presidente
fernández es un mensaje de integración
de un modelo de integración diferente
me pone me parece que está que es
correcto que si el presidente de maduro
y otros presidentes que lo han
felicitado también por su participación
se sintieron contenidos en este discurso
donde lo que se precisa para la región
son nuevos instrumentos de integración
donde todas las voces estén presentes
bueno esos positivos pensamos que es el
camino
pensamos que las exclusiones no debieron
llevarse adelante en esta cumbre y que
la cumbre debió haber contenido a todos
los países
dicho esto el presidente fernández
asumió con mucha responsabilidad también
en la presidencia de la celac y desde
ahí entendió que era necesario plantear
un mensaje profundo sobre sobre los
desafíos que tiene la región actualmente
desafíos con respecto no sólo a
cuestiones vinculadas con los países o
con individualidades sino con
externalidades que ya venimos padeciendo
no solo a la salida de la pandemia sino
también ahora la guerra en el corazón de
europa la invasión rusa sobre ucrania
que ya tiene consecuencias en la región
ya vamos a ahondar también quisiera
ahondar en el tema de la guerra de rusia
contra ucrania pero quisiera volver al
tema de la decisión del presidente
fernández entonces de venir acá porque
también una delegación de eeuu que
estuvo en buenos aires un senador un
cristo asesor de la casa blanca y se dio
a conocer que iba a haber una visita
también en una reunión bilateral tuvo
esto que ver también para incentivar la
decisión del presidente fernández de
venir él personalmente y no que fuera
usted el representante de argentina
nosotros somos respetuosos y obviamente
que recibimos a todos en nuestro país
y si traen mensajes alentadores en
cuanto a las necesidades de encontrarnos
y respetarnos entre todas entre todas
las opiniones de la región siempre vamos
a hacer receptivo y receptivo en la
argentina de una política exterior que
es una política exterior amistosa en
general de la argentina no nos genera
problemas no todo lo contrario lo que
busca es que haya mesas de discusión de
debate de negociación pero pero siempre
la herramienta es la palabra nunca la
fuerza argentina
siempre promueve ese tipo de vínculos lo
que determinó que el presidente venga
justamente es
quizás esté terminar de definir cuál es
el mensaje que él iba a dar aquí
y hacerlo con total honestidad y creo
que eso vale mucho porque
hablar dignamente tener un uso de la
palabra aquí en una cumbre estas
características y aprovecharlo para con
mucha dignidad dejar planteado cuáles
son los desafíos reales y sin ponerse
colorado de lo que de lo que se ha hecho
mal hay muchas cosas que creemos que se
han hecho mal en la región y eeuu es un
gran responsable de eso bueno no es esta
administración no es ahora es quizás una
acumulación de errores pero sí
lo que esta administración de eeuu tiene
la posibilidad de revertir esto de
revertir su relación con américa latina
y el caribe
y creo que esta cumbre bueno le permitió
me parece que le permitió a eeuu y a
muchos conocer y entender en mayor
profundidad qué era lo que estaba
pasando en la región que realmente
estamos con con situaciones de
desigualdad muy profunda y que
necesitamos un modelo de integración que
promueve el desarrollo económico en toda
la región canciller y si bien hay muchas
cosas que se han hecho mal de parte de
parte no extraer este mensaje de
venezuela de alguna manera
y darle un apoyo a gobiernos que han
evidenciado que hay violaciones a los
derechos humanos que hay presos
políticos no pero nosotros no trajimos
el mensaje de venezuela del mensaje
pronuncio presidente argentino si el
mensaje que pronunció el presidente
argentino en también en su carácter de
presidente pro témpore de la celac
sí sí otros presidentes quieren dar sus
mensajes cada uno hace el uso de la
palabra lamento que aquí no haya estado
invitado o venezuela o cuba bueno es
algo que se dijo en muchos presidentes
lo remarcaron
porque en última instancia hasta así si
otros países tienen críticas sobre el
desempeño de esos de esos esos gobiernos
tenerlos sentados en una mesa para
manifestarse los es el camino adecuado
el camino de poder entender que que se
pueden pronunciar críticas y quizás hay
actitudes receptivas
con respecto a la argentina la posición
nuestra es la de que la de encontrar un
espacio donde la argentina
no está para repartir sanciones bloqueos
o señalar país en argentina lo que ha
elegido es justamente promover el
diálogo en promover el diálogo es con
todos sentados en la mesa bueno
canciller y hablando nuevamente de la
guerra rusa en ucrania
el gobierno de argentina se había
acercado de alguna manera durante la
pandemia a rusia por la distribución de
vacunas que ha pasado con esta relación
ahora en este nuevo contexto
la argentina promueve el
multilateralismo y ese multilateralismo
se construye a partir de relaciones con
todos los países lo que la argentina
hizo con la federación rusa es promover
acuerdos comerciales o tratar de
promover acuerdos comerciales tenemos un
muy bajo muy bajo
[Música]
a nivel de comercio con rusia por rusia
y lo que la argentina está buscando son
nuevas fuentes de financiamiento de
proyectos productivos en ese sentido se
inscribe el viaje del presidente
fernández que aparte fue previo a que
suceda lo de la guerra digamos no
claramente todo todo eso quedó en un
mundo pasado en un tiempo pasado de los
que hoy ya no hay posibilidades de
revertir nada de eso
lamentablemente lo que el desenlace de
la guerra ha provocado consecuencias
humanitarias muy profunda en argentina
ha condenado esa invasión la argentina
lleva adelante los visados humanitarios
para y es receptiva
ya que son refugiados lucran ya y la
argentina es el país junto a brasil que
más ha donado más donaciones ha hecho en
la región
a los
espacios de refugiados que están tanto
en polonia como en rumanía así la
argentina tiene una actitud muy
proactiva muy con humildad pero pero ha
trabajado fuertemente para tratar de
acercar soluciones concretas
lo que
lo que sé lo que creo es que está mal
interpretado es que la argentina haya
buscado aproximar una relación comercial
y me parece que aparte es es un tiempo
que era diferente no había guerra cuando
pasó eso
creo que lo más importante aquí es que
siga bien claro cuál es la posición de
la argentina del continente en general y
la gran mayoría se han manifestado en
esa dirección de condenar una guerra
porque porque el américa latina y el
caribe es una zona de paz
y es una zona de paz porque porque no
está de acuerdo y ya siempre rechazado
el uso de la fuerza como un mecanismo
para resolver conflictos
y esa zona de paz es lo que a nosotros
nos permite hoy tener un testimonio muy
fuerte en este mundo incertidumbre de
qué cuando nos respetamos cuando tenemos
memoria cuando generamos mecanismos
donde todos estamos en la misma mesa y
todos nos escuchamos y todos tenemos la
posibilidad decirle al otro qué cosa se
está haciendo mal esos son los los
espacios de integración que tenemos que
promover y es desde ahí es donde
nosotros podemos decir
y reafirmar que américa latina es una
zona de producción canciller última
pregunta sobre este tema se continúan
recibiendo vacunas sputnik de rusia no
hace tiempo ya no las compras que
hicimos ya se culminaron
se hace creo que un año pero fue una
vacuna que funcionó muy bien yo creo que
no hay que mezclar las cosas tampoco
muy bien que la argentina la compro no
es que no fueron donadas ni mucho menos
un fue un acuerdo comercial
los llamativos que se sigue hablando de
esto y sin embargo en la mayor cantidad
de vacunas que hay en argentina son de
faisán la segunda
en las una marca de vacunas que más hay
en la argentina son de astrazéneca
y recién la tercera
la tercera o cuarta o la tercera es
china sino farc recién la cuarta es la
isla sputnik pero bueno evidentemente
acá hubo como una especie de tensión y
diplomacia de vacunas que estuvo en el
mundo que nosotros lamentamos porque a
veces esas cuestiones ideológicas hacen
que
que se tensionen en la accesibilidad de
las vacunas y nos parece que no es
adecuado la argentina hoy uno puede
encontrar vacunas de todo tipo y color
de los países así que es como le digo
la mayor cantidad de vacunas que hay una
argentina no es ni mucho menos de ser la
cuarta bueno y cuál es para usted el
mayor logro de esta cumbre de las
américas en los ángeles creo que haberlo
logrado y que se haya hecho el encuentro
es importante me parece que ahí hay es
el punto principal la posibilidad de que
se haya generado un espacio encuentro es
lo más positivo
luego la profundidad de las conclusiones
creo que es más discutible hay muy poco
para rescatar con respecto a los
compromisos programáticos que tienen que
tener los países para
para generar modelos de desarrollo
inclusivos en nuestra región para
resolver cuestiones concretas como la
desigualdad para avanzar en políticas
educativas o
o de lucha contra el cambio climático
nos parece que toda esa agenda que
denunciada en algún punto
pero no hubo compromisos tan firmes de
los países como para poder avanzar
sin embargo insisto con esto quiero
quedarme con lo positivo que fue
el encuentro el espacio del encuentro
y eso es es relevante en un mundo de
tanta incertidumbre que tanto el mundo
de guerra en el corazón de europa de
tanta desconfianza ya que nos hayamos
juntado
una gran cantidad de países del
continente es importante significativo
canciller de argentina santiago
cambiaron muchas gracias por su tiempo
para france24 ya ustedes gracias por
permanecer con nosotros sigan viendo
france24 y trans 24 punto com